plus de peur que de mal la nuit dernière
en centre ville de tours un bar à chicha
a été complètement détruit par le feu
vers 2 heures du matin les habitants de
l'immeuble ont été réveillés par la
police arrivée rapidement sur les lieux
miracle aucun blessé n'est à déplorer
les faits avec lucas chopin deux heures
cette nuit la place de la résistance
s'embrase une patrouille de police
découvre lé incendie et fait évacuer
l'immeuble théophile se trouve au
quatrième étage dans l'alignement des
flammes je suis en train de dormir
j'entends que ça tambourine à ma porte
j'entends les forces de l'ordre me dire
police ouvrez ouvrez alors je ne
comprends pas vraiment ce qui se passe
je me retourne dans mon appartement pour
prendre quelques affaires je vois des
flammes à travers la fenêtre alors que
j'étais au quatrième étage donc j'ai
tout de suite compris qu'en fait il y
avait urgence et j'ai couru j'ai couru
pour évacuer tout de suite l'immeuble
c'est un bar à chicha qui brûle et qui
aujourd'hui est entièrement détruit
l'incendié n'a pas fait de victime
seule une personne importunés par les
fumées est resté en observation cette
nuit à l'hôpital bretonneau plus de peur
que de mal donc
alors même que de jeunes enfants se
trouvaient dans l'immeuble avec les deux
enfants vont aller vite les lever du lit
et on les a pas trois millions et demi
de couverture on est descendu à fond
mais ils ont pas trop vu ce qui se
passait ils ont pris le temps de se
réveiller je crois qu'il a bien trop
mais j'ai pas vu une enquête est en
cours pour connaître l'origine de
l'incendié dérivera explique t'avoir vu
l'établissement accueillir du monde
récemment malgré le couvre-feu